[Musique]
député modem des yvelines bruno myle yen
vient de lancer un groupe d'échangés de
réflexion baptisé confluence yvelines il
nous en parle aujourd'hui d'entretiens
politiques bonjour brno millions jours à
vous et bonjour à celles et ceux qui
nous suivent pourquoi ce nouveau groupe
de réflexion déjà alors c'est vrai qu'il
y en a beaucoup des groupes de réflexion
des think tanks entendu comme on dit en
bon français mais celui là est née à la
suite de l'extraordinaire abstention des
élections départementales et régionales
et là on est un certain nombre à s'être
dit faut quand même à un moment ou un
autre on reconnecte la réalité de
l'action publique avec les citoyens et
qu'on échange avec eux un peu façon
grand débat sur des thèmes qui les
préoccupent et moi je m'interdis pas 1
ou à l'issue de ces réunions de serre
remonter aux différents ministères les
conclusions qu'on en tire on va parler
cette abstention déjà sur votre
structure justement alors c'est pas un
parti c'est un spa un groupe c'est ta
politique en tout cas c'est la politique
et c'est toute la difficulté de
l'exercice pour moi en tout cas je vais
être tout à fait honnête là dessus c'est
d'arriver à me déporter de ma fonction
de député alors dans les introductions à
chaque réunion publique je le fais et je
précise bien qu effectivement ma partie
mon rôle de député sera plus de remonter
des informations de différents
ministères ou gouvernement mais je veux
un échange calme respectueux serein je
prône la nuance et la modération qui à
mon avis aujourd'hui sont des vertus
cardinales qui tiennent du courage et de
l'héroïsme en cette période de radigues
ali radicalité à tout crin pour le
moment ce sont plutôt des élus de droite
du centre qui vous ont rejoint la grèce
n'a pas pu il ya quelques élus il c'est
vrai qu'il ya quelques élus c'est plutôt
des élus centristes oui je ne vais pas
vous le cacher mais y'a à ma grande
surprise des universitaires des
commerçants des entrepreneurs enfin des
gens de la société civile en général qui
est qui viennent sur un lieu des changes
encore une fois qui se fait dans le
respect dans le calme et dans la
réflexion et non pas dans l'invectivé
comment ça va fonctionner justement
alors on est en train de s'organiser
parce que j'ai lancé ce milieu de l'été
donc c'est compliqué on va pas tarder à
déposer des statuts d'association on va
monter ça parce qu'il faut quand même
une structure un peu qu'on veut pas
juste faire ça comme ça donc je vais je
vais pas tarder à envoyer un courrier à
tous ceux qui m'ont soutenu dans la
démarche pour qu'on fasse cette
association et après il y aura des
réunions de cette structure qui définira
les thèmes des réunions publiques qu'on
fait et les débats qu'on doive à des
citoyens pour effectivement essayé de
les raccrocher à l'action publique parce
que les gens ont l'impression que ça
n'atterrit pas chez eux mais
contrairement à ceux qui pensent souvent
ça a été vraiment chez eux dans leur
quotidien une première réunion publique
il ya déjà eu lieu c'était mi septembre
nous avons rencontré quelques-uns des
participants justement écouter les la
démarche m'intéresse de rassembler le
plus de monde possible et du débat donc
je pense que c'est toujours bien de
débattre et surtout que des fois on a un
sentiment que les français s'éloigne de
la politique alors qu'en fait les
enfants tous les jours mais ça les
intéresse mais peut-être pas les débats
de partie et c'est plutôt
constructif et c'est important de
débattre sur les sujets de la société
actuelle qui nous impacte dans notre vie
quotidienne
donc c'est important de débattre de tout
ça même qu'il idées d'interaction avec
les uns et les autres se trouvent une
façon permettre justement peut-être des
coûts découvrir certaines personnes
qu'on peut faire de la politique
autrement
faire de la politique autrement alors
c'est pas un slogan très neuf non plus
parce que si je me souviens bien en 2017
un certain emmanuel macron on avait fait
sa marque de fabrique aussi pour ce
faire il ya ça veut dire que depuis 2010
est on n'a pas réussi à faire de la
politique autrement
c'est compliqué de faire de la politique
autrement au niveau national moi je m'en
suis aperçu parce que je m'étais engagé
là dedans et vous commencez à me
connaître un petit peu je crois pas
avoir beaucoup changé dans la façon dont
on exprime par rapport à avant quand
j'étais pas député après vous avez le
poids des partis politiques vous avez
aussi et ça il faut que les français en
soient conscients l'action
gouvernementale quelle que soit la
majorité
l'action gouvernementale est souvent
dictées par la réalité par les
circonstances du terrain donc vous êtes
80% de l'action je pense est dictée par
ça donc il ya la partie effectivement et
c'est là où nous les français doivent
ressentir un décalage il ya toute la
partie campagne électorale où
effectivement il ya un projet qui est
posé on essaye d'aller vers des choses
qu'on pense pouvoir réel et après il ya
la réalité de l'action gouvernementale
qui fait que je n'arrivais pas à
réaliser forcément tout ce que vous avez
mis dans votre projet et puis depuis
deux ans ça a été plutôt compliqué de
mettre en oeuvre sa brouille avec la
situation malgré tout sur ce quinquennat
alors là vous allez dire que je suis fan
mais malgré tout sur ce quinquennat si
vous regardez vraiment le projet initial
qui a été porté pendant la campagne où
on en est aujourd'hui 77 80 % des
propositions ont été faites ont été
réalisés quoi les électeurs n'ont plus
confiance et encore moins aujourd'hui on
a vu l'abstention encore la grossière
durant ce quinquennat c'est pourquoi les
électeurs n'ont plus confiance je pense
qu'il ya dans la rue ça veut unique de
fait d'abord les organisations de ces
élections intermédiaires juste à la
sortie
du confinement ce n'était pas forcément
le bon choix au niveau des dates nous on
avait prôné enfin en tout cas moi
j'avais prenez pour que l'on fasse les
départementales au moins deux comme
maîtres m'ont été faites les
départementales et régionales mais qu'on
décale les régionales au mois de
septembre pour laisser un peu le temps
aux gens finalement de respirer avant
d'aller sur quelque chose et puis les
élections intermédiaires je crois
traditionnellement de toute façon sont
beaucoup plus d'abstention parce que les
gens ne comprennent plus rien à notre
niche mille feuille institutionnel
donc il ya beaucoup de choses à faire
mais malgré tout c'est une tendance et
c'est une tendance forte contre laquelle
il faut combattre et quand on voit les
entrées en politique des différents
candidats aujourd'hui quand vous voyez
les catalogue à la prévert de mesures
qu'ils annoncent moi je comprends que
les gens n'aillent pas voter si je
reprends parmesan pas d'amis d'algos qui
ne dit qu'elle va doubler le salaire des
professeurs elle c'est pas possible ou
de l'autre côté de l'échiquier quand les
extrémismes disent on va renvoyer tous
les étrangers délinquants chez eux on
sait que c'est pas possible donc il faut
arrêter de raconter des sornettes aux
gens les gens sont informés donc il vaut
mieux être le plus transparent possible
je sais pas si la transparence totale
existe mais en tout cas le plus
transparent plus honnête possible et
dire aux gens ce qu'il est possible de
faire ou pas et essayer d'avancer avec
le là dessus mais c'est enfin il n'ya
pas le nouveau monde et l'ancien monde
ya une façon de faire de la politique et
notre façon de faire de la politique les
débats que vous allez organiser au sein
de votre groupe de réflexion justement
vont porter sur quels sujets très précis
alors on ya des thèmes différents là on
m'avait fait démocratie numérique parce
que pour voir l' influence du numérique
effectivement sur l'action démocratique
et justement sur cette cette absorption
qu'on a eue le prochain aura lieu à
guerville là le 20 octobre joue là non
ça sera sur l'agriculture et la
nécessaire transformation agricole et la
nécessaire transition écologique de
l'agriculture et ça sera fait avec un
grand émoi qui est lui même agriculteur
qui était con agriculteurs
conventionnels et qui est passée bio sur
les différents groupes de réflexion mais
a néanmoins tout de même une question
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure en
introduction il en existe beaucoup des
fameux think tank dtcc groupe de
réflexion donc pourquoi ne pas touchent
les fusionner tous travailler ensemble
si l'idée c'est justement d'être
apolitique de réconcilier globalement
les électeurs la différence peut-être de
confluence avec les autres c'est que les
les principaux think tank on connaît
travail finalement ans vasco entre
experts il ya de temps en temps de
l'association doit de la société civile
mais c'est toujours des experts qui sont
associés là nous ce qu'on veut faire
c'est vraiment porter des sujets du
quotidien dans le débat public avec les
citoyens sur le terrain et c'est cela en
fait je pense aux différents est-ce que
c'est déjà une manière pour vous de
prendre un petit peu des idées avant de
faire campagne
l'année prochaine pour les élections
législatives en parce que parallèlement
à ça on travaille sur le sur le projet
sur le projet
du futur peut-être candidat macro pour
2022 moi je travaille
en ce moment en plein sur sur sur le
programme écologique que pourrait
présenter le présent macron pour 2022 et
en ce qui vous concerne c' est ce que
vous serez candidats pour les
législatives
eh bien écoutez la première des
questions c est ce que je serais pas
investie si je suis réinvesti oui je
serai candidat pour un deuxième et
dernier mandat je n'en ferai pas plus de
2 pourquoi de penser parce que je pense
que tout comme le président de la
république a droit à deux mandats je
pense qu'à un moment il faut laisser la
place aux autres et que le premier
mandat on apprend beaucoup en fin de
mandat on est en capacité d'avoir des
actions plus prononcé et le deuxième
mandat c'est le le mandat pour faire
réellement les choses au plus près du
temps quel est votre regard sur la
discussion politique justement vous en
parler un peu tout à l'heure vous parler
de ces inventaire à la prévert mais
forcément période électorale il ya des
propositions il faut arrêter c'est à
dire qu'aujourd'hui les propositions
nées du mal à les entendre on n'est plus
dans la déclaration la petite phrase
mais il n'y a pas il n'y a pas vraiment
de propositions parce que malgré tout ce
que les gens disent si vous regardez cet
axe central qui s'est créé avec l'arrêt
mais le modem puisque c'est les deux
piliers ton permis à emmanuel macron
d'être élu si vous regardez mais
vraiment attentivement et pas seulement
ce qu'on dit dans les journaux ce que
veut mettre en exergue notamment les
chaînes d'info si vous regardez vraiment
objectivement ce qui s'est fait d'une
part pour les entreprises est lui
beaucoup de choses de faites donc côté
entreprises entreprises je pense que
cette majorité a été plus loin que ce
que la gauche droite pouvait imaginer et
côté social parce qu'il faut le regarder
aussi on n'a pas assez regardé personne
parle en ce moment vous savez ces
histoires de pouvoir d'achat personne ne
repense à la baisse des cotisations
salariales mais la baisse des
cotisations soit et ça a été formidable
une formidable augmentation de pouvoir
d'achat pour les français dont ils ne se
sont pas aperçus parce que ça s'est
répercuté directement sur leur fiche de
paye sans qu'il s'en aperçoive forêt qui
regardent leurs fiches de feuilles au
fur et à mesure du mandat donc et il ya
eu beaucoup baissé comme difficile
d'expliquer aux gens votre pouvoir
d'achat s'est améliorée alors
qu'aujourd'hui on voit bien les factures
d'énergie we con mais ça a explosé
c'est pas c'est pas contradictoire c'est
pas parce que le pouvoir d'achat a
augmenté plus sur ce quinquennat qu'il
n'augmentait lors des deux dernier
quinquennat que pour autant on n'a pas
un problème de pouvoir d'achat j'ai pas
dit ça j'ai dit que l'augmentation de
tournage a été ré allianz plat sur les
mesures sociales on a fait plus que la
gauche n'avait jamais fait ou osé faire
donc il faut que les gens soient soit sa
conscience et du coup la droite
traditionnelle la gauche traditionnelle
sont un peu enfermé dans une espèce
d'impasse ou de cul-de-sac où elles vont
effectivement trouver des espèces
d'annonce josé valérie pécresse sur
l'immigration un changement la
constitution elle sait que c'est pas
possible à faire mais c'est pas grave
elle le met dans son programme enfin ça
c'est pas possible
voilà bat et battons-nous sur le terrain
des projets des idées mais des trucs
concret pragmatique et réaliste pas des
trucs qu'on sort comme ça dans ton dont
les gens savent pertinemment que s'il
gagne ses candidats ne les applique ont
pas parce qu'ils ne pourront pas les
appliquer on va aussi quand même dans le
débat politique et peut-être vous en
parlerais au sein de vos groupes de
réunions aussi que la part d' extrême
progresse malgré tout dans les sondages
d'opinion si on regroupe tous les
extrêmes 53 500 ils sont à plus de 30%
ne sont pas censés partis sont à plus de
30 pour cent avouent bélanger je crois
que les extrêmes je compte les droits de
l'échiquier politique extrême gauche
comme droite ça c'est une vraie
préoccupation et c'est une préoccupation
pas seulement françaises c'est un truc
que la passion mondiale c'est à dire que
le modèle social auquel on est rattachée
nous depuis la révolution française qui
est plutôt la démocratie ce modèle là
est attaqué de toutes parts partout dans
le monde et il est attaqué chez nous
évidemment par les extrêmes parce que ce
soit où que ce soit jean luc mélenchon à
côté ou zemmour et
marine le pen de l'autre quand on les
entend parler de liberté s'il leur
liberté mais c'est des libertés qui vont
emprisonner les français si vous
regardez bien leur programme on peut pas
mettre quand comme la gauche le veut
tout l'échiquier français au même niveau
et on peut pas mettre comme la l'extrême
droite le voeu que la préférence
nationale comme comme comme ça nous on
est comme porte-drapeau merci ono mylène
député des yvelines on se retrouve
bientôt sur tv soixante dix huit pour un
prochain entretien politique et je
rappelle donc que vous avez mis en place
ce groupe de réflexion confluence dans
le département
[Musique]